uh so you uh tell me because you've kind
of been doing so much outside of the
music space
um what has inspired you to drop new
music actually you know what
um the first go around it was more about
the business of the music for me okay so
I was more focused on the business and I
didn't get a chance to really enjoy it
right you know like I'd enjoy it it was
all business but I said the second time
around I want to be able to really enjoy
it man take it breathe it in and enjoy
it all of this luxury that you know we
work for because it don't even make
sense man and then I watched the younger
generation how to get this blessing to
make this many
opportunities and millions around the
things that they do and they just out
here killing themselves yeah yeah it's
like what is the purpose like to do all
that to get out the hood just to bring
the hood with you also like uh it's
probably different now because you're
doing it just because you want to not
because you have to right so when you
first got into the music industry you're
like this is my way out yeah yeah sure
so you got to treat it as such a job
that's a bigger difference and then you
know like the way I feel like about you
know about the life now is like okay
cool I made some good money Investments
are all secured My Legacy isn't a good
place it's like okay now I can really go
back into the music and have fun but
then again I kind of miss the music too
because it's been I didn't realize how
much time I flew past when's the last
time you dropped a scene 2008 was the
last time I dropped the record was that
Smack That
now the last one was beautiful okay okay
okay I remember that record yep that was
the lasting a long time it's been a
minute that's 14 years yeah I mean
you've hopped it like you know hopped on
people's stuff you know here and there
yeah you know some collabs here and
there but that's wild that is crazy bro
that was pretty crazy 14 years man I got
a 17 year old yeah that [ __ ] is wild